it wasn't so easy but we have with us
already in the studio the man is fast
not only over the board but running here
to the studio to be with us sam savion
the winner of the 2022 spring chess
classic group a sam congratulations
first and foremost tell us about your
event
uh yeah first of all i'm extremely happy
to win this event i had many ups and
downs during the tournament but
managed to get through them
successfully you had a surge in that
second half of the event it just seemed
that you started off with a few draws
weren't able to convert all your
positions and then suddenly boom boom
boom wins wins wins plus three score at
the end there had to survive a little
bit of a scare today against jeffrey but
besides that a pretty smooth sailing
yeah i mean the fourth round when i was
playing against daryush i was completely
winning and
when i kind of blew that game i kind of
got angry and started playing better
you have not only searched in this event
but for the past year you've been
surging in the world rankings what have
you been doing differently in training
that's a tough question
um
i i mean i'm just generally playing a
little faster i have a big problem with
time pressure and
that's definitely
i've changed that the past couple years
was that also the strategy going into
this playoff play as fast as possible
because we know that nishnik is a very
quick player yeah definitely in
especially with two second increment
which is basically nothing it's
definitely good to have a couple minutes
minutes up on the clock
alejandro i mean the man is a legend
after this event he just completely
dominating the dominated event i'm
really happy to see him do so well of
course as we mentioned so many times the
us olympic team is so tough but
everybody is like a huge fight for that
fifth spot and it's certainly good to
see new talent especially talent that's
been around for a very long time here at
the saint louis chess club sam i think
you played the first us championship
what was it 2013
yeah 2013 when it was twisted i should
remember that because i played
it with that tournament but great to see
you the success
very well deserved excellent chance you
showed dominant performance here
especially in the first game of the
playoff congratulations
this was great thank you big congrats
sam thank you
well thank you everybody for joining us
here we have it there winner of the a
group sam savion
perfect score not losing a single game
of chess here in st louis he can
definitely be happy with this one a plus
three finishing up the tournament
and it's not just the plus three right
it's the way he did it he he did not
lose a single game not even in the
playoffs and he didn't even have a
chance it's not that he got lucky and he
like bounced back maybe the last round
against jeffrey and even that one you
can think there was there was chances
for jeffrey but it wasn't even clear-cut
i mean there was an advantage but not a
decisive advantage but going into the
playoffs ilia was